hey everybody welcome back to Jaeger
horn I know you're probably never gonna
get tired of my terrible pronunciation
of German I am sorry about that I
actually went to phantasialand a few
days ago and I once again embarrassed
myself trying to order things in
restaurants but yeah what can you do
about it
oh maybe trying to improve at some point
in the future in any case that's not the
point of this video the point of this
video is that I'll be building a
building more specifically this video
will be all about one building in one
building only which is the Gift Shop of
the ride and to be honest I was
struggling with what kind of thing I
wanted to build in this corner for the
park because you might have noticed that
that brown spots has been here almost
the entirety of this series also maybe
brown spot isn't the best word to use
for this kind of thing the the muddy
terraforming here mmm doesn't sound much
better but yeah this this little
demarcated area has been here for quite
a while because I've been planning to
put a building here for a while but I
never really knew what I wanted to place
here and only recently I figured that a
gift shop might as well be the best
thing I think scenery wise it makes
somewhat sense because it allows for a
little bit more fancy billing than just
these other little restaurants of toilet
or whatever it's a good size for the
plots as well because a gift shop
doesn't need to be quite sizable because
you're realistically have to fit quite a
large room for all the merchandise but
it also automatically kind of works I
think usually you find gift shops at the
exit of a ride which helps the park to
force people to walk through the gift
shop as they exit the ride which is you
know helping them to buy stuff
impulsively that they didn't want to buy
but they find themselves buying anyway
because they're kind of forced into the
gift shop you know capitalism but in
this case there isn't really space to
doing that kind of thing but I think
this is just about the the next best
place to put this since its run in front
of the entrance it really sits at one of
them the main hubs of the path a really
good viewpoint as well and this path is
sort of between the entrance and the
exit as well so if you're going to this
part of the park explicitly to ride this
coaster this is the one part of the park
that you're going to walk
in any case so yeah because of that I
think this is a pretty good place to
build a small gift shop that said I do
have to say I'm not going to get into
interior design as much as I would love
to and as much as I want to try it at
some point I'm really just going to keep
this quite simple and pretty much
pretend that this is a real gift shop
but just put a few stalls at the front
of the building and that will be it
maybe at some point in the future if I
feel like doing interiors I could get to
that kind of thing but I think for this
park especially given how very detailed
it is already I want to just stick to
the outside that said and I think I've
teased this at some point in the past
but I don't think it hurts to say it
again I will get into the interiors of
the station at some point at least that
is the plan I'm just not sure yet when
I'm gonna do it it might be in a sort of
wrap up episode when I get to all of the
parts that are sort of left unfinished
across the park but there is definitely
going to be some interior work in this
park it's just that I have no clue how
to make a gift shop actually work and
how much time it would take me to get it
to work if at all so we're just sticking
to the outside look here by the way I
just want to thank you guys really
quickly for the amazing support on the
last video I really wasn't expecting the
bridges video to kind of blow up that
way but even even though it hasn't
exactly blown up or anything it got
something around double as many views as
my videos of this series usually gets
and so many positive comments and I even
got people sending me private messages
and stuff about it so I didn't have a
lot of time to say this kind of stuff in
the comment section so unfortunately I
didn't leave a lot of comments there so
I just want to say it here thank you
guys so much for the amazing feedback on
the last episode I know this this video
isn't going to be as great as that one
was but I really wasn't expecting so
much positive feedback so that was
really awesome to read in any case let's
get back to topic so I didn't really
talk about what this building is going
to look like or
my philosophy behind it is if you will
so let me go ahead and give a bit of an
introduction to it my preparation for
this building kind of existed of looking
up some Belle Epoque kind of Alpine
architecture again and I saw a lot of
these arcade like buildings and lower
pavilion like buildings which have these
overhanging roofs with pillars on the
sides with some very decorative sort of
patterns on it and that was something
that I wanted to incorporate in this
building because I think it makes a
really inviting foundation for a
building and a really great space to a
really really great space I'm trying to
say space in place at the same time
doesn't really work out very well to
place all of the the small gift shops
and stuff like that because you get
these xx1 tile grid spaces between the
pillars which makes them just about
perfect to have a bunch of counters
behind them and line them up with all
kinds of different items so that was
also kind of a plan behind this building
but I think overall it's a slightly more
inviting design than just building very
simple Alpine buildings and it also I
think brings the whole thing together
the existing facades that we have on the
other side of the park all kind of look
like separate buildings but because of
this one sort of gallery on the ground
floor I think this one as a whole
manages to look as a single building
even if the elements are kind of
different and if they kind of rotated in
relation to each other the great thing
about this is also that you can really
just look up some reference pictures
because I get this question a lot it's
like what kind of thing do I do
to get inspiration or where do I get my
information from and a lot of it is
doing 3d Google Maps saying around parks
to get inspiration or actually looking
up websites for info on certain
architectural styles but a lot of it is
also just going to Google Images and
going just on it on a huge search spree
which can sometimes just take more than
an hour or even hours to find examples
of what I'm try
to do and kind of take things from that
so in this case specifically I think
it's it's nice to draw from the Swiss
Chalet style because it gives very clear
elements to kind of work with so I'm not
lifting the overall design of the
building from anything or the the basic
structure but all of the elements are
kind of picked from different examples
so if you look at the pillars there are
very similar to pillars that you might
find in a lot of these kinds of
buildings there's the the cross bracing
with the one vertical little beam
between the pillars is kind of
decorative arches and that is really
just something that you find very often
in these kinds of buildings that's not
really a pattern that I came up with
just something to lift from these images
which I'm using as a reference and pull
on it and then the rest of the building
like the part on the rights with the
cable and all of the wooden decorations
everything is kind of lifted from a
different thing so all of the wooden
framework on the stucco is is based on
one building and then the gable
decorations are based on some other
building and in this sense it's kind of
a Miss mishmash of different kinds of
reference pictures which is a way that I
really like to work in because it also
kind of allows you to pick out a lot of
stuff and while I'm google searching
just kind of go oh I would love to use
that kind of gable structure or I would
love to take those kinds of pillars and
it makes my work a little bit easier
because well I wouldn't really call it
work but it makes playing the game a
little bit easier one that doesn't sound
entirely correct either it makes making
this stuff a little bit easier because
you don't really have to come up with
everything on the spots and you can base
a lot of what you're doing on existing
stuff but on the other hand it's also
really fun because you're sort of
picking what the building is going to
look like while you're searching for
reference pictures already so I came
across those pillars and those arches
with those kinds of decorations and I
figured hey I might put that in this
building and kind of safe that and kept
it open as a reference to use later on
and in that sort of way I also like to
get an idea of what I want to do in my
mind before I start building so that a
lot of
what you're seeing me do here isn't
really me going to try different things
it's really just trying to replicate
what I have in my mind to do in the game
using the in-game elements which to this
day is probably still one of the most
challenging but also one of the most fun
elements because obviously you're trying
to recreate real-life architectural
elements with a very limited amount of
pieces that we have in planet coaster
and really coming up with ways to look
at the pieces and figuring out new ways
to use them is always something that I
found one of the most fun things to play
the game for so by now the building is
already looking almost finished except
for this part on the left this part on
the left isn't really going to be
anything I didn't think I would have to
make it too inviting because it's really
in the corner and this is a bit of a
dead end so really the whole souvenir
and drinks and I think it says
chocolates on the side there is all that
I really thought was too importance this
is really just on the left is really
just a little bit of a decoration and
trying to finish up the building I don't
exactly remember what I did over here
again I know that I also base this on
some existing buildings but it's a
little bit of a a town house or a little
farm house that's kind of stuck into the
rest of the building in a way I also try
to experiment as much as I can with
mixing these different wooden textures
and little items together because I find
if you keep using the same planks and
the same details all over building and
especially if you keep using the same
ones throughout different buildings
things start to look still very quickly
so what I like to do is try to mix all
of these different detail elements
together to make them look slightly
slightly more unique and slightly less
like they're supposed to look like so
there's a lot of mixing different wooden
beams together with roof trims and other
such elements to create a slightly more
and slightly less recognizably in-game
look to this building
I am NOT going to do the backstage areas
by the way in this kind of decorative
way I think this was a question which
was asked in the comment section of the
last video if I remember correctly it
might have been the comment section
before that but I'm pretty sure it was
the last video where people were asking
me if I'm going to do some kind of
backstage areas in this park to which I
should say I'm gonna do them but they're
gonna be quite simple so these buildings
are really just going to be facades
there is not going to be decoration like
this on the back of the buildings as
though these are real buildings these
are just decorations slept on her fake
buildings so the the back sides is some
things that I do want to get to but I'm
just going to make it very simple
there's just gonna be gray boxes or
whatever really works to make sure that
you could functionally run this as a
theme park but at the same time I will
definitely make the backs of these
buildings areas that guests are not
supposed to see so in that sense it's a
little bit disney-esque which is a bit
of a discussion I guess for another time
because what I have seen a lot of people
do is add these kinds of backstage areas
to any kind of park but really if you
have a more traditional sort of
organically grown a theme park and by
organically grown I don't mean any kind
of farm or anything but really just I
think a theme park that kind of grows
over time and because the van has a very
organic layouts you normally don't
really see these kinds of backstage
areas because buildings are really just
buildings and they're not fake shells of
a building so if you look at the
efteling for example a lot of the
buildings are really just actual
buildings built out of brick and with an
actual backside which looks very similar
to the to the front and the same goes
for a lot of family owned theme parks or
very small regional parks in many of
those cases I would say it isn't really
necessary to build these fake backstage
areas but in this case I think this ride
could fit somewhere in a very heavily
themed park
I believe this was also asked in the
recent comment section what kind of park
I would see Jaeger horn being in to
which miles would be something like
Europa Park I think would be very
fitting
obviously they already have an Alpine
area but this Alpine area lifts a lot
from that one it's also quite compact
which fits in in the the basic scenery
of Europa Park which is very dense and
kind of Disney like almost the theme
park I could also see this fitting in
Fantasia land at least theme wise but I
don't know if phantasialand is ever
going to get another very simple scenery
area because all of their recent
projects from Chiapas to Black Mamba to
Teheran to now fly our super dense and
really built on top of each other which
is something that I definitely kind of
want to try in planet coaster at some
point it seems like a fun challenge but
Jaeger horn is definitely a lots more
spread out there's a lot more space to
work with here so I don't know if it
would fit in Fantasia land when it comes
to space use but uh scenery wise I would
definitely see it in a park like that I
think it could almost go for an efteling
look as well if it had a little bit more
of an F tooling flair here and there so
I could see that happen as well in any
case I think it would probably be at a
European Park perhaps some kind of
Disney park but then again it's not
really an ip-based right so
realistically I wouldn't really see that
happening so Europa Park is where I
probably see this most in any case I
just totally skimmed over the fact that
I built a small entrance gates for the
queue really isn't all that much just a
simple roof I'm also going to have to
add some fences to it at some point
because the first part of the queue is a
little bit unfinished and then next to
it just to kind of fill space here
because I didn't want to leave this dead
and without something interesting to
look at that wouldn't really draw in
guests and I also think that wouldn't
really make it clear that this is the
actual entrance of the ride so because
of that I wanted to place a small clock
tower over here which has a bit more of
a Tyrolean design at least I haven't
seen these things in Switzerland and I
don't think they're a very typical
appearance
Switzerland whereas I've seen a lot of
these wooden bell towers or clock towers
in in Cairo and Austria but that said
I'm not entirely sure about the
background of these things in any case I
think they look really neat and I always
wanted to try and build one in planet
coaster so here it goes
a little bell tower made out of wood
just to give you something interesting
to look at and to draw guests into this
part of the park and with that little
creation we've come at the end of this
episode so I would like to thank you
guys for watching once again just as a
little info notes I am going to
Scandinavia I'm going to Denmark and
Sweden right now at least tonight and
I'll be there for about five six days
and in the meantime hopefully this
should be uploaded to YouTube and I'll
try my best to stay active but also I'm
gonna travel back to Scandinavia for two
weeks almost later this month
and I'll also be travelling to Poland at
the end of this month to ride hopefully
hyperion which is already booked and is
kind of stressing me out it's for a few
months already but yeah because of all
of that I'm gonna be pretty busy so I
don't think my upload schedule is going
to be quite what I would like it to be
but I'll try to keep uploading at least
every week and also I still have some
vlogs under my belts so you'll see those
come up along with the Wallaby vlog
which should have recently came out so
yeah thank you guys for watching and
I'll see you next time